hey I have a sort of a declaration to
make and I think some people will find
it interesting last week we got a live
call about the topic of sex offender
registries and during that phone call I
said that you can sort of make the case
that any post sentence impacts are
potentially unconstitutional because
once you've paid your debt to society it
would follow that that's it
there's a clean break and there should
be more there should be no more post
sentence impacts and I didn't really
feel as though I was informed enough
about the specifics of the sex offender
registry I have no fear about revisiting
my views or revolving on certain issues
when I think that I have a better
understanding and I dug into this one
for a while over the weekend and I am
now ready to say that beyond the
question of the legality or morality of
any post sentence repercussions I am
also specifically against the sex
offender registry and I want to talk to
you about that today the best argument I
can make for the sex offender registry
is that sex offenses are a type of crime
that present such a risk to society such
a risk to children that we should handle
them specially compared to for example
burglary or tax fraud so that neighbors
can look you up to see if you were
around and be aware of the danger that
you present and I really spent a long
time looking into this and it doesn't
really make any sense it's not a good
argument number one I have found no
evidence that sex offender registries
actually help to reduce the number of
sexual assaults that's the I've just
found no evidence of that whatsoever
number two when I dug into what makes up
sex offenses as a category it turns out
that most are within family and friends
they're people that the victim knows
they're not offenders who would stalk
and attack strangers and so for the most
part having a public list of these
individuals wouldn't actually help in
that case number three as we've talked
about before so many sex offenses go
unreported which is a major problem so
at best it's a very incomplete list and
the reality is that sex offenders are
everywhere regardless of the list period
number four there are a ton of acts that
count as sex offenses that really
shouldn't some states if you urinate
publicly you are a sex offender in some
states if you take naked pictures of
yourself when you're a minor you're
listed as a sex offender in some states
soliciting prostitution makes you a sex
offender indecent exposure also known as
public nudity in some states makes you a
sex offender and that's not really a
group of acts for which we need a public
list that people can be looked up and
most importantly and we've talked about
this so many times pat getting out of
prison is tough reintegrating into
society is difficult if you're a sex
offender being in prison is even tougher
partially because our prisons aren't
that great at keeping certain types of
offenders safe
the last policy I want to support is one
where I'm putting people on a list that
is ineffective at doing what it claims
to do that will further stigmatize
people and make it more difficult for
them to find housing and to get a job
period so for me Pat the focus should be
identify the fraction of sex offenders
that are more likely to reoffended that
took pictures of themselves or the guy
peeing on the side of Fenway Park when
the Red Sox won the World Series focus
on those likely to Rhea fend her reduce
the likelihood of them reoffending
period because the sex offender
registries don't appear to be making a
safer and they seem to perpetuate the
problems of incarceration tell me I'm a
flip-flopper
but I've done the research and I now
feel that this is not a good policy no
your position on this evolved much like
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama's
positions evolved on gay marriage in the
early 2010's the early part of the
decade when we had a live caller last
week Colin and talked about this I
remember that you were able to identify
how we had this idea in America that you
serve your time and once your sentences
though
you can kind of reintegrate fully into
society but that doesn't always bear out
because we have things like felony
disenfranchisement in some states we
have things like the three strikes laws
in California but I was thinking you
know as progressives we're also against
those two things so would it stands to
reason that we should also be against
the sex offender registry that's kind of
where I came out on this topic and
ultimately once I got past the
statistics of how effective it is that
that was a big factor for me as well so
I am against the sex offender registry
but I'm willing to have my mind changed
again just reach out to me and let me
know what I'm now misunderstanding and I
know that some of you nice folks are
going to do that I await your emails and
tweets and Facebook messages and YouTube
comments